sa place au top de la mode vous aviez
vous des avec le feu une balle a dit
avec de la compote
tout commence comme un véritable conte
de fées avec une merveilleuse pyramide
de victuailles les prophètes les
volailles bien sûr des homards encore
vivant la famille toute la maison va se
retrouver réunis dans une commande
ducation c'est à dire l'acte magique de
manger ensemble un repas
mais grâce aux plans douce a remplacé le
foie gras maintenant et les huit cantons
à près de la mer c'était le réveillon
moment j'aime beaucoup
[Musique]
on grimpe alors du pain avec selon eux
mangent les châtaignes avec la salade
mêlée jour de fête en corse le menu avec
du saucisson et du jambes
[Musique]
comprendre
est ce le christ et ses 12 apôtres est
ce chiffre cabalistiques de 13 qui
intervient très souvent ou bien est-ce
peut-être une plaisanterie elle nous
devait brûler queue par un bout
réchauffez éclairer la maison toute la
nuit de noël et jusqu'à l'épiphanie
[Musique]
des projets il fait on monte en fait sur
les nichons vous saignez problème le bon
petit vin du projet